OK, we have to demand that.
Corporate media live fact check, Donald Trump's
corona virus, press briefings.
You all may know that I've been covering the
press briefings live roughly five, six days
a week.
Usually I miss one each week that Trump does.
I make an effort to be as.
Hot up as possible on all of the things Donald
Trump is likely to lie about.
So that in real time I can fact check it.
When Donald Trump says chloroquine looks really
good, I'm ready to tell you that it is one
of dozens of things being looked at.
But the early trials aren't so good.
And a lot of them lack the rigor that a true
randomized, controlled, peer reviewed trial
would have.
Okay. Trump says chloroquine +s throw myson.
Why not?
What do you have to lose?
And I make an effort to be ready with what
you might have to lose.
And the side effects, chloroquine poisoning,
so on and so forth.
This week, Trump shifted his zinc.
Zinc does not cure coronavirus.
And we have to be ready to talk about that,
Trump said last week.
Sometimes a scarf is better than a mask at
preventing contagion.
That's not true.
We have to be ready with the data.
There's been a huge debate about whether corporate
media outlets should air the Trump press briefings
or not.
Should they skip the Trump part and go right
to the doctors?
Well, the problem with that is very often
in the midst of the lies, Trump is actually
announcing important policy during his part,
whether it's an extension of the social distancing
guidelines or whatever.
Trump says no one could have predicted this.
We've got to be ready to point out, actually,
a lot of people were predicting it.
So here's my challenge to corporate media
and I encourage you to let them know.
And to his credit, Joe Scarborough actually
said the other day, MSNBC has to be alive.
Fact checking these.
They are so riddled with lies, they have to
be live, fact checked.
The challenges demand that corporate media
live.
Fact check the press briefings, put a 90 second
delay on it, 90 seconds on.
Google is more than enough for a team of producers
to find the truth about the things Trump is
lying about.
If by myself, I can catch half the lies, a
fully staffed multi-million 10 million hundred
million dollar operation has to be able to
handle the research and the graphics required
to live.
Fact check these press press briefings.
Airing them without fact checking is really
easy to do.
Airing them, not airing them at all is easy
to do.
It's easy to critique as well.
Right.
The the real work, the value earn, you know,
should show us that you're worth something.
Is the message to corporate media is to run
them.
But live fact check.
And you know, for the media outlets that like
triggering Trump, like it seems pretty clear
at this point.
CNN likes to trigger Trump.
And they've been you know, it's typically
CNN asking some of the tougher questions.
And good for them during the press briefings.
It's sometimes CNN that we'll just skip Trump's
part altogether.
I guess CNN wants to trigger Trump.
You're going to really trigger him by running
a real time ticker, correcting his lies.
MSNBC, to their credit, I believe they did
jump in.
They had a doctor jump in when Trump mentioned
zinc on I think it was Wednesday this week,
they had a doctor jump in and say, this is
bogus.
There's no evidence that zinc treats coronavirus
in any way.
And it's it's simply not true.
That's good.
You don't have to have a guest there the entire
time.
Just have people who know how to search the
Internet, find the truth about the lies that
Donald Trump is telling and do it.
My message to you in the audience is demand
that they do it right to them.
Tweet them, tell them you must live fact check.
They have the resources.
The question is, do they have the political
will and do they have the strength to bear
what Donald Trump clearly will rain down upon
them for doing it, which is not going to be
good.
Trump is going to be furious about it, but
they should do it.
It's a service to the American people.
It's a service to the world, really, because
the disinformation that Trump spreads often
goes global.
It doesn't rise much like the virus.
It doesn't respect the borders of countries.
We've got to make them do it.
Let me know what you think about that suggestion.
Is that the best strategy for corporate media
with the press briefings?
I'm on Twitter at Dipak.
Quick break.
Back after this